hi everyone it's charlie happy comic-con
week we gotta talk about some of the
really big easter eggs in the spider-man
far from home
in credits scenes so there's a really
innocuous moment that doesn't seem like
a really big deal as part of the bigger
end credits scene that winds up being
this huge easter egg for the fantastic
four
kevin feige even had to come out
recently and say something about it
so it's happening during that web
slinging scene when he's on his way
to meet mj that i attached the clip of
at the beginning of this video
so we'll explain the scene and what it
means for the future of marvel
especially given what kevin feige came
out and said after everyone started
talking about the easter egg
because it's comic con week there's a
new round of that imax ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a spider-man
comment on the video i'll name a new
winner at the end of this
and it should go without saying but
spoiler warning for spider-man far from
home if you have not seen the movie yet
because we'll be talking about what
happens during the post-credits scenes
so i've already done a couple videos
about the end credits scenes there's a
mid credit scene in a post-credits scene
for the purposes of this video we're
talking about something that happens
during the mid credit scene before you
get to the jay jonah jameson scene where
he appears in the mcu for the first time
so at the end of the movie peter parker
confronts happy and aunt may after they
got
back to new york city about their
relationship they have this funny joke
about them implying that maybe we're
just gonna see where things go
maybe they'll stay together maybe not
just a joke about what the plot of
spider-man 3 might be for these two
characters
spider-man's totally grossed out he
takes off because he has a date with
mj in the new steve ditko suit tom
holland said that they referred to it as
the bosco suit on set but i still think
of it as the steve ditko suit because
that's the look that they're going for
the classic original steve ditko
spider-man suit
he swings through new york city giving
us what we haven't seen
in a long time in a spider-man movie
showing just how much better they've
gotten
displaying the physics of spider-man i
feel like they really nailed that during
this film in all of his web slinging
scenes
much more beletic version of spider-man
that we've seen in previous versions
they had started to get there it's just
the special effects have started to
finally catch up with what your
imagination can come up with based on
the comics
but we haven't really seen a big
web-slinging scene like this through new
york city that looks amazing since
andrew garfield's amazing spider-man
there's a moment during the scene when
he's running across the rooftops there's
a green goblin easter egg i'll do a
separate video about
if you thought you spotted a green
goblin easter egg during this moment
here then you
are correct but that's a whole different
thing we need to talk about in a
separate video
little things might seem like no big
deal but it takes a lot of people
working on visual effects to make
spider-man swing through the city like
this
they manipulate the images so much
anything you spot is no coincidence
while he's swinging his way to mj he
stops and glides through a new opening
in the newly redesigned avengers tower
with the mystery buyer that we still
don't know about yet
more about that in a second but when he
swings down through he hangs on a pole
swirls around and then lands on the
ground if you look in the background of
this shot you can see a very large
construction sign
in front of that avengers tower that
says we're so excited to show you
what comes next and it's really only on
screen for a couple seconds so almost
blinking you miss it
but there's a one two three in a
question mark where the four
should be so this is an easter egg for a
bunch of different things
the colors of the numbers correspond to
the colors of the fantastic four
characters in their powers
the fact that the four is a question
mark is a reference to
marvel phase four coming next like you
don't know what it's going to be because
we haven't told you yet but we're really
excited to tell you
but it also represents the invisible
woman from the fantastic four because
it's a question mark like where did the
number four go you can't see it because
the number four
is invisible like the invisible woman
the street corner that peter and mj are
standing on is also very important for
this too because east 41st in library
way
is just a block away from where the
fantastic forged
baxter building is in the comics
so i know a lot of you are wondering now
if the fantastic four are the mystery
people who bought the avengers tower
from iron man in spider-man homecoming
and kevin feige's recent comments is
also kind of important for the way you
interpret this fantastic four easter egg
so it should go without saying that this
probably does not mean that they're
going to debut the fantastic four in
spider-man 3. they're not trying to tell
you oh they're coming right up next
it's more of a wink of comic book easter
eggs as well as future stuff in marvel
phase 4
without any really hard dates on
anything like of course there's going to
be a new fantastic four movie but they
haven't told us when it's coming yet or
who the actors are going to be
another really good example of a really
cool easter egg like this that doesn't
necessarily mean things are happening
right away
is the venom easter egg yes there is a
venom symbiote easter egg that happens
earlier in the movie
in venice when he's fighting the big
hydro man monster i'll do a separate
video about that too because it is
pretty cool and it's a nice wink at the
symbiote saga in the comics
but they're not trying to use it to say
that peter is going to be wearing the
symbiote in spider-man 3.
[Music]
so be careful that you don't take a lot
of easter eggs as being super literal or
them
nailing themselves into a corner about
what's coming right up next
kevin feige recently came out because
people were asking him there's a sign
there is the fantastic four of the
people that bought the avengers tower
and he says you know we love to watch
people speculate on marvel movies and
find these easter eggs
but oftentimes a lot of speculation
winds up being incorrect
so all he was really saying is is that
don't assume that the fantastic four are
the people that bought the avengers
tower that could still be anybody so if
you're still holding out hope that
ozcorp
is the people that bought the avengers
tower it's still possible that they
could use that because it does sound
like based on the end credits with jay
jonah jameson outing spider-man
spider-man home run he's going to be
running from a lot of his villains all
over new york
city in spider-man 3. i really do like
spider-man home run
is the title of spider-man 3. you could
do it run home but i think home run just
plays a little bit better
when you think about the scope of the
second post-credit scene with nick fury
on the sword
space station and what that means for
the future of marvel movies it also
means that they're pushing in a much
more scientific space based direction
and this just provides a lot more
opportunities for fantastic four
characters to get involved they're known
as marvel's first
family in the comics but they're also
marvel's first science-based family
because of mr fantastic
they're the original science bros of
marvel comics because they debuted
before most of these other big
characters that we've seen in the mcu
there been a couple scenes in recent
marvel movies that have hinted at
fantastic four in norman osborne green
goblin
oscorp things remember ant-man and the
wasp there's a lot of stuff going on
with the quantum realm just a whole lot
of territory for them to explore if they
do more ant-man in the wasp films
if they don't they can just use that in
other people's films a la fantastic four
because what is one of the biggest
concepts to come out of some of the more
recent fantastic four titles
the idea of the multiverse the idea of
the negative zone so you just have a lot
of marvel characters traveling the
multiverse if anyone's going to do that
fantastic four characters would be great
for that if they don't want to double
down on ant-man and the wasp and stature
now because remember we're in 2023 so
cassie lang is still a teenager old
enough
to take the mantle and become a hero in
training with her father
there was a really cool deleted scene
during that movie of the actual quantum
city within the quantum realm
it implied that janet van dyne had been
living there with those beings and she
had sort of been altered
a lot of theory crafters are trying to
use this as a potential path to x-men
because they talk about the way she was
fundamentally
evolved like she's no longer totally
human then you have deleted scenes like
this where she talks about the life
forms down there
there's so much we didn't know about
this place henry
worlds upon worlds entire civilizations
far
more than we ever theorized
[Music]
so when you're thinking about marvel
phase four fantastic four multiverse
just start to think in that direction
and i still get a ton of questions about
mysterio's story during the movie about
the multiverse was he lying about the
multiverse
the good thing is is they already
established that of the doctor strange
movie so all the scientific stuff that
he's talking about
is still sound the only thing that he
was lying about was his actual backstory
being from another earth in the nature
of the elementals
we could use someone like you on my
world i'm sorry your world
mr beck is from earth just
not ours there are multiple realities
peter this is earth dimension 616. i'm
from earth 833
we share identical physical constants
level 4 symmetry i'm sorry
you're saying there's a multiverse
because i thought that was just
theoretical i mean that completely
changes how we understand the initial
singularity
sorry paul rudd has said that he's not
totally sure that they're gonna make
ant-man the wasp three so he's like
people please start a petition
so it just hasn't been completely
confirmed what they're going to be doing
with quantum realm fantastic four next
in the mcu
but the really good news is is that
marvel phase four's comic con panel is
happening
in one week as i'm posting this video
some of you probably won't see this
video till a little bit later
of course i'll do videos for whatever
they reveal but let me know in the
comments
what do you want them to do with the
fantastic four when they bring them
officially
into the mcu do you want a solo movie
first where they reboot the characters
or do you want to see them appear
in somebody else's movie first that
venom easter egg video in the green
goblin easter egg video should post in
the next couple of days
there was also a really funny chris
hemsworth thor parody that he just
posted so i might do a separate video
about that too
but congratulations to hitendra patel
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so i can get
your details
click here for that new avengers endgame
deleted scenes video and click here for
all my other easter eggs from the
spider-man far from home and credits
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight